everything costs more right now
including health care we connect with
the Southern Nevada medical insurance
broker who explains why and what our
clients are going through
frankly people are overwhelmed for more
than a decade Ozella renewal has been an
insurance broker for Tyler Insurance
Group in Las Vegas and Pahrump right now
she's in the midst of helping people
navigate an overlapping open enrollment
period with Medicare and the Affordable
Care Act it's a stressful time for
everyone especially as inflation is upon
us and it's increasing and she's having
to relay the message Health premiums are
also increasing as a seasoned broker she
helps people tailor their plans for the
next year some will see slight increases
in premiums because theirs were
finalized in the fall of 2021 but some
new carriers are seeing double-digit
increases I was hoping my premium for my
family would not go up a hundred dollars
but when you're showing the other
carriers it's 150 200 more than the
carrier I'm with and as inflation
continues to grow we could potentially
observe a higher increase in average
premiums for 2023. each year as we have
open enrollment it's it's a difficult
discussion to have with your clients
because rates are not getting lower I'm
needing to help people responsibly
budget their health care for their
family and I I hear them on the phone
saying well I'm going to cut out this
membership or I'm going to cut doing
this because I need to have health
insurance
Ozil renewal encourages everyone to find
a broker you trust as a broker works for
their clients not the insurance
companies medicare's enrollment period
goes until December 7th open enrollment
for the Affordable Care Act goes through
January 15th